[Musique]
mademoiselle chase
quelle est la toute première chose que
vous vous rappelez quand vous étiez dans
la simulation personnes se souvient de
rien pourquoi on s'est retrouvé là alors
c'est quoi notre bateau a fait naufrage
on n'est ni mon nom on est sur une île
on sait pas comment on a atterri là elle
va bien falloir qu'on survive il faut
qu'on tienne prêt ou alors on se tire
d'ici
ça promet d'être beaucoup plus intense
encore si vous agissez mal il vous rend
la monnaie de leur pièce
elle m'inspire pas confiance
vous l'attendiez
si tu as une hallucination
je crois que je commence enfin à
comprendre ce qui se passe
si là-bas vous est resté
ici aussi rebuy
[Musique]
chaque choix très déterminé la suite
vous croyez qu'ils pourront s'en sortir
l'homme est mort je ne crois pas que
cela
toute ma vie vient le raphia